yeah welcome to this video playing gap
button shocked this Bulgaria right
khabar shook but he's called your dad
evil off not borislav even off the
cheetah at least an LED gdm here okay so
one open Sicilian came I prefer to go
for classical development I don't really
know them shop online so get them may
blind scream traveling on a venir and
Bishop d7 this is I think the old move
rookie eight is the more modern approach
so of course a playable move so g4 or
not yeah can first play that booth rock
on d8 don't see that too often so
usually Oh interesting okay gawa I don't
am NOT an expert so probably moves that
commonplace to surprise me I mean I'm
not an expert in this particular opening
normally black plays rook to e8 and and
so that you have some some count to play
on the foul he didn't do that here I
played a rock to d8 and be sure to v8
yeah no I'll I get back to d4
intensifying the pressure on e6 I'm not
sure you want to play Bishop d7 back
here
especially you don't want to take 00
this is a very sharp sharp idea yeah I
guess I can take him maybe I could have
taken only six but don't want to fall
too far behind on the clock if he
recaptures with any wave I'll play f6
our Knight takes of course I first
exchanged okay here we go it should be
for coming next maybe you can play pawn
to d4 hmm maybe she thought about this a
bit longer hmm t4i looks looks a bit
ugly yeah oh just do it this is surprise
I mean this looks looks like completely
like devastation that here that he
allows this okay let's see what am i
overlooking yes this made on g7 no this
is what I overlooked okay yeah it still
looks looks very nice for white but
still
yeah I won't create Queens you can
forget about that not with this King
position who night before 12 6 really
let's go that quickly yeah I think it
was just a really terrible attack anyway
but Knight coming to have six okay if I
just give this check Queen g5 Evans and
chef
yeah just 25 on Queen somewhere to g7 I
don't black resigned yeah I don't think
he can event that yeah Wow I mean this
looks this looks very very dangerous
anyway but yeah okay the computer gives
a direct win for white but it's a
computer not a human being I was a bit
afraid about d for trying to muddy the
water need to take and then have a min
this pin here it's probably not
important yeah yeah it is not important
I can take g7x move and then once the
night it's just such a deadly pin black
doesn't have any way to to use this
something like that i have 95 down okay
then then deform wasn't helping guide
this is just just a flat win no way to
defend this position at all yeah i'm not
i'm not really sure and I don't know the
opening well but this looks this looks
super dangerous to me already yeah like
really needs to defend accurately here
after that it's erm it's it's probably
probably almost impossible to defend
yeah this is just too much you need to
want to play a different set up this
attack is too strong no way to to defend
the King yeah it's just too little too
little defenders and I've got all this
coming here
nope alright thanks for watching